thank you alejandro with the man of the
hour right now number three in the live
rating list in the blitz section fabiano
carona let's start with the obvious tell
us a little bit about this shirt uh with
these two kitties and the chess team
what's the story behind it
well there's not much of a story uh it's
it's actually the same cap
it is the same guys is this your cat
yeah
excellent well definitely a lucky charm
for you in this one how did you approach
today's uh rounds you started off four
or five points behind the leader what
was your strategy yeah i mean i didn't
think i have much chance in the fight
for anything
uh and in the first game i blundered the
central pawn against richie
uh
but somehow i won that game i was lucky
that my blunder wasn't very serious and
after that i think i played
uh quite well um
i mean i played a number of quite
excellent games i think for for blitz
standards against wesley i was quite
proud of that one and some other games
as well i thought i handled it quite
well
uh so yeah any shaky moments throughout
the day did you feel that at all under
pressure in any of the games well when
you get down to seconds you always feel
under pressure like this game against
bishop was a bit crazy
he ran out of time but i don't know
exactly which moment he did so i think
we played played quite a while after he
ran out of time
uh but i think i was mostly pressing
that game and
definitely winning at various moments
maybe not in the final position but
uh that was a shaky one
and um i don't know i mean there was
you know time scrambles are always quite
nerve-wracking
now almost reminiscent of your run at
the sinkhole cup in 2014. seven and a
half out of eight and eight out of nine
did you find any similarities
no
not at all
um
i mean i normally don't go on runs like
this in blitz
but yeah it's also
it is just blitz
i can't really compare it to
achievements in classical chess which
are at least i value uh significantly
more
uh but anyway it feels very good
especially when you're playing good
chess and i think for the most part i
did five points behind the leader going
into today's rounds two points behind
the leader going into the final day how
do you assess your chances going into
that one if i play like today then i i
definitely have chances
um
but yeah every day is different you know
sometimes you think you're in form
sometimes you think you're in bad form
like in rapid i was playing terribly and
then suddenly i played quite well today
and then tomorrow is uh is a whole
nother another story uh it's not
guaranteed that i'll continue playing
like this fabiano congratulations
looking forward to see your matches
tomorrow thank you guys back to you our
congratulations to fabi most